- [Instructor] Let's say
someone walks up to you
on the street, and they
give you this expression,
x squared plus seven x plus 10
divided by x plus two.
And they say, "See if you
could simplify this thing."
And so pause this video,
and see if you can do that.
And one way to think about it is what is
x squared plus seven x plus
10 divided by x plus two?
What is that going to be?
All right, now there's two ways
that you can approach this.
One way is to try to factor the numerator
and see if it has a factor
that is common to the denominator.
So let's try to do that.
So we've done this many, many times.
If this looks new to you,
I encourage you to review
factoring polynomials other
places on Khan Academy.
But what two numbers add up to seven
and when you multiply 'em you get 10?
Well, that would be two and five.
So we could rewrite that
numerator as x plus two
times x plus five.
And then, of course, the denominator,
you still have x plus two.
And then we clearly see
we have a common factor.
And so as long as x does
not equal negative two,
because if x equals negative two,
this whole expression is undefined
because then you get a
zero in the denominator.
So as long as x does
not equal negative two,
well, then we can divide the numerator
and the denominator by x plus two.
Once again, the reason why
I put that constraint is
we can't divide the numerator
and the denominator by zero.
So for any other values of x,
this x plus two will be
nonzero, and we could divide
the numerator and the denominator by that.
And they would cancel out,
and we would just be
left with x plus five.
So another way to think
about it is this expression,
our original expression,
could be viewed as x plus five
for any x that is not
equal to negative two.
Now, the other way that
we could approach this
is through algebraic long division,
which is very analogous to
the type of long division
that you might remember from,
I believe it was fourth grade.
So what you do is you say,
all right, I'm going to
divide x plus two into
x squared plus seven x plus 10.
And in this technique, you look
at the highest-degree term.
So you have an x there
and an x squared there.
You say, how many times
does x go into x squared?
Well, it goes x times.
Now, you'd write that in this column
because x is just x to the first power.
You could view this as
the first degree column.
It's analogous to the place values
that we talk about when
we first learn numbers
or how we regroup or about place value.
But here, you could
view it as degree places
or something like that.
And then you take that x,
and you multiply it times
this entire expression.
So x times two is two x.
Put that in the first degree column.
X times x is x squared.
And then what we want to
do is we want to subtract
these things in yellow from
what we originally had in blue.
So we could do it this way.
And then we will be left with
seven x minus two x is five x.
And then x squared minus
x squared is just zero.
And then we can bring down this plus 10.
And once again, we look at
the highest degree term.
X goes into five x five times.
That's a zero degree.
It's a constant, so I'll write
it in the constant column.
Five times two is 10.
Five times x is five.
And then I'll subtract these
from what we have up here.
And notice, we have no remainder.
What's interesting about
algebraic long division,
we'll probably see it
in another video or two,
you can actually have a remainder.
So those are going to
be situations where just
the factoring technique
alone would not have worked.
In this situation, this,
this model would have been easier,
but this is another way to think about it.
You can say, hey, look, x
plus two times x plus five
is going to be equal to this.
Now, if you wanted to
rewrite this expression
the way we did here and say,
hey, this expression is
equal to x plus five,
we would have to constrain the domain.
You'd say, hey, for all x's
not equaling negative two,
for these to be completely
identical expressions.